listen to your Aunt Ellen this is a
pretty big story in my
opinion thank you Aunt H whatever deck
the halls with jingle balls lifetime
recently announced its first ever
Christmas movie sex
scene and a cowboy Christmas romance
yeah because nothing gets America in the
holiday spirit than sitting with Grandma
and the grandkids watching The Grinch
get a lap dance from Mrs
Claus and a warning to all you stripping
elves Ebenezer Scrooge is a lousy Tipper
the lead actress boasts that the film
barely mentions Christmas at all and
lacks many of the familiar cliches of
holiday films but is the lifetime
channel making the right move by
injecting sex into their Christmas
movies I guess we shouldn't be surprised
in this day and age when your product
sucks you just add sex just like public
school oh yeah cat um
even in movies that have sex scenes
they're unnecessary they just make
everybody uncomfortable why are they
doing this to America no you know what
my favorite Christmas movie is what eyes
wide shut oh
yeah it's technically a Christmas movie
it really it did happen in December so
yeah yeah and Tom Tom Cruz is
technically an elf but also I mean yeah
the whole the it is if Lifetime movies
Christmas movies people do watch those
with their family so sometimes the
reason something hasn't been done yet
isn't because it's just this great new
idea it's cuz everybody else has
realized it's not a good idea yeah Todd
uh will you be watching this with your
family absolutely not sex has no place
in basic cable made for women Christmas
movies that's why Greg why my family and
I will be watching The Hallmark Channel
with such wholesome titles as Norwegian
holiday a not so Royal Christmas magic
in mistletoe and Christmas with a kiss
Just a Kiss Greg I will not be watching
Christmas in Bon toown on Lifetime yes
I'll be on my channel will be on
Fox where we will be airing Christmas in
bone toown s great Gutfeld there'll be
every Christmas uh everybody will have
uh little you know cut and paste jobs
you know I won't be cut and paste
jobs that's what we call it in TV Land
denan is this what women want you're a
woman
um redneck first and this is they're
falling back on the old uh heaw
yeah stereotype with this uh they get it
on in straw which is the worst
yes the wor the worst is sand no it's
not no it's not do you guys argue that
after straw mites and blister beetles
that is all you need to know when it
comes to
sex and straw yeah espe especially when
afterwards the woman says talk about a
needle and a hay
stack thank
you thank
you even with the flu I can entertain
you uh Mike do you think there's some
kind of CIA relationship with the
lifetime channel why would they be there
has to be something go in the ious even
no no no no it's it's we we are not
associated the CIA has a long-standing
association with the Hallmark Channel
thank you uh you couldn't name a
Hallmark Christmas movie that my wife
and I haven't watched a um yes it uh
it's it's the perfect romantic uh uh
thing uh you know wow good it's that
sort of talk that really attracted my
wife to me if they're going to do if
they're going to put sex scenes in
Christmas movies what is next you know
what they should do I was thinking about
this you know every company has HR
corporate training films like for sexual
harassment they should put sex scenes in
that see what they're doing right there
can't do that if you're working you guys
work together shouldn't be doing
that guy com in from the other from the
not that either and no sir Bob that
thing with the copier no no hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else